Hey guys, we went to Swig.
Swig is the soda shop in Utah that does crazy soda flavors
and they have a drive through.
So we got a bunch to try. The first one we got is Riptide.
Both lucky and I don't drink soda with caffeine,
so we got all the caffeine free options.
This is Riptide. It's Sprite,
cranberry, raspberry puree and lime.
I got triple lime because I'm a lime addict.
Yeah, this is good.
What do you rate it out of 10?
A 6. A 6.
I don't taste the triple lime,
I'll be honest.
This is island time. Lucky got this in a 32 ounce.
I don't know why, but, um. Fresca.
What's fresca? Passion fruit,
fresh orange, mango puree,
coconut cream.
Why do I feel like this is not gonna be fizzy?
That is insane.
That is so good. I like it.
Very good. Very good,
very good. Eight out of 10.
I give it a nine. It's stunning.
I don't. I didn't think I'd like it.
We got kid sizes cause we knew we weren't gonna drink it all.
So this is cinnamon, cider,
ginger ale, lemonade,
cinnamon apple and a cinnamon stick.
I don't know about. I don't know about this one either.
No,
it's enough for me. No. Three out of 10.
We have pink Bahama. Yes,
we do. Yes we do.
What's in it? Fresca. Peach,
strawberry, raspberry,
fresh lime. Wait,
that actually sounds insane. Haha.
I get you. So Right, Mama?
Oh, I'm underwhelmed.
Love it. 7 out of 10 5 called popping pineapple.
It has Sprite, pineapple, watermelon,
strawberry, popping pearls. Oh,
it should have given us a bigger straw for this.
I don't care about it at all.
Two out of 10?
Try 10. Right?
Maybe three. The last one is the Tropic.
What's in it? Lemonade,
mango, passion fruit,
vanilla cream.
Wait, I'm actually intrigued.
That's good, but I.
Let you tell me what's off with it.
It's not fizzy. It's not fizzy.
And, like,
isn't the vanilla just so, like, thick?
One out of 10. One out of 10.
Negative zero. Negative 10.
That's a little harsh. I would give it one out of 10.
My overall favorite is one I ordered Island Time.
Island Time. Mine is a tie between Island Time and Riptide.